but we want to start tonight with Justin
Bieber and Baldwin's big surprise a
source tells ET Justin and his fiancee
Haley Baldwin secretly tied the knot
after obtaining their marriage license
at this New York courthouse last month
what's strange is that the couple kept
it a secret from a lot of people close
to them and Haley even denied it
outright on Twitter there's no legal
reason for them to lie but one thing
that it has done is it's kept us all
guessing and it certainly increased the
drama around the relationship Haley was
out yesterday on Melrose Avenue wearing
her engagement ring but no wedding band
keep in mind we're told the couple still
plans to have a formal wedding ceremony
the speculation right now is that it
will be in Canada where Bieber is from
and where the couple despite at Sunday
making a coffee run during a brief trip
last weekend Haley's cousin and Alec
Baldwin's daughter Ireland told us to
expect an intimate official ceremony I
think she loves
just family and being close does it feel
right for you guys it was meant to be a
long time ago it was just a long time
coming and we're all like alright thank
God well here forward now whoo
yeah totally but there's another twist
there are new reports today that the
couple tied the knot without a prenup
keep in mind that Justin's fortune is
worth an estimated two hundred and sixty
five million dollars Haley about two
million it's really insane to not have a
prenup family law attorney Robert
Wallach says if the couple divorced in
the near future Haley would not be
entitled to Justin's vast fortune just
what he made while they were married
still that could be a lot if you
consider Justin made eighty three
million dollars last year they
definitely should get a post-nuptial
agreement a post-nuptial agreement has
the same effect the same legal effect as
a prenup except it's signed after the
marriage rather than before
[Music]
[Applause]